so the NAACP is calling for tourists to
stay away from Florida it issued a
travel advisory over Governor Ron
DeSantis policies like restricting
School investment in diversity equity
and inclusion programs the group saying
this Florida is openly hostile toward
African Americans people of color and
lgbtq plus individuals before traveling
to Florida please understand that the
State of Florida devalues and
marginalizes the contributions of and
the challenges faced by African
Americans and other communities of color
Florida Congressman Byron Donald's
firing right back
I don't even know what the NAACP is
talking about this is silly and it's
dumb it's political it makes no sense we
should be focused on making sure people
actually have the opportunity to achieve
which Florida is actually doing and
thriving in way better than other states
let's say New York or California or
Washington State we're doing a
significantly better job helping black
Americans succeed and it's not just
about me it's about all the millions of
black people that live in our state
Dave Rubin is host of the Reuben report
you have moved from California to
Florida you just heard from Byron
Donald's let's get your take
um one I do think the NAACP is looking
for a little bit of publicity they are
getting it but so is Ron DeSantis
sure well look every word that the NAACP
put out in that statement is complete
and utter nonsense now it is true that
we are eliminating diversity equity and
inclusion from our institutions in
Florida but that is racism when you
Whittle everyone down to their skin
color and then decide who can get into
what school or what job or whatever else
it might be Byron Donald is completely
correct if you want to come to Florida
regardless of the color of your skin and
you want to enjoy our fresh air and our
good weather and our low taxes and our
strong infrastructure and our safe
cities things of that nature you should
be here there is absolutely nothing
racist going on in Florida there is far
more neo-racism happening in New York
and California and some of the other
places that Byron mentioned the NAACP
might want to look into how many people
were shot for example in Chicago this
past weekend 21 people shot in Chicago
this past weekend I'm pretty sure they
were all black that did not happen here
in the Free State of Florida call for
number two just Florida tourism numbers
are off the charts more than 137.5
million tourists visited Florida last
year and visitors spent about about 100
billion dollars in 2019 that's the last
time figures are available for that but
Dave can I ask you they also include the
lgbtq plus community in this why
well first off Dana you know there
really is no such thing as the lgbtq
plus community and the L's and the G's
and the B's better start separating from
the trans Community the trans activists
these radicals who want to deny biology
and often cause irreparable damage to
say some kid who might just be a 15 year
old gay boy who hopefully grows up to be
a functional adult or a girl who maybe
grows up to be a lesbian or or a
straight woman who knows these things
are radically opposed to each other
there is no group out there that is more
anti-gay than the trans movement so
there is nothing going on here that is
stopping gay people or even trans people
by the way from living fully actualized
lives in Florida there were no laws
about what adults can do with their
lives or what they can do in the privacy
of their own home the only thing that
DeSantis has done related to this that
seemingly has gotten the entire
mainstream media in an uproar is that he
doesn't want drag performers putting on
sexualized shows in front of children we
all know that is true that has nothing
to do with sexuality or anything else
like there is a reason that you have age
of consent and things of that nature and
uh and unfortunately Dana you know this
the media just lies about absolutely
everything but black people are
flourishing in Florida because it is a
place of Freedom gay people are
place of freedom and you only have to
look at the numbers that you referenced
it's the amount of Tourism that comes
here and it's 1200 people a day who are
still moving here uh regardless of their
skin color or sexuality right Dave Rubin
we'll see how this all plays into F at
all Governor DeSantis
president this week Dave Rubin thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell